You taught me about Islam and Christian
heroism. Thank you. You're welcome. Can
you teach me more about honor, strength,
virtue, spirit, and how to obtain such
things? I want to learn these from you.
Thank you. Wow. Yeah. Well, first I
commend you for even realizing that
these this this is what really matters.
Honor, strength, virtue, and spirit.
That is really the source of uh that we
we seldom talk about. and you know and
why I don't talk about it though I do
think about it often and have strong
thoughts on these matters that you just
raised about honor and so forth and I've
done a lot of reading in old books about
it um they don't exist anymore. Have you
ever thought I'm glad you bring this up,
but things like honor and virtue? Let's
just let's just stick with honor, okay?
And virtue, which are very much the
same. And honor, okay, here's the thing.
What do those words even mean today? I
know what they mean. Do you ever hear
anyone talk about honor and virtue? As a
society, who ever brings up honor and
virtue? It used to be back in olden days
amongst let's say the Romans, honor and
virtue was something you're going to
teach children. Do we ever talk about
honor and virtue? Do children know what
what does that even mean? These are
meaningless words. Okay. How about
masculinity? How about femininity as
opposed to feminism? And I always find
that ironic. The same root, two exact
opposite meanings. But that's the
society we are. These words have lost
absolute meaning. all meaning and they
need to come back because without things
like honor, virtue, you know, spirit,
being noble, and I don't mean like
aristocracy, noble, not your blood, but
just behaving noly. Does anyone even
know what that means anymore? Do these
words have any meaning? Used to be that
societies were built and governed by
these words,
okay? Honor and virtue and uh strength
and um discipline. Okay. Um, yeah, these
are not the things that we're taught.
These are not the things that our
society prizes. We're taught the exact
opposite. As I mentioned before, I did a
little sort of deep dive in what's
called the seven deadly sins.
Let's see if I remember them. I always
forget.
Pride, wrath,
lust,
sloth, gluttony,
envy.
You see, I got six this time. Usually I
stop at five. Anyway,
that those things were considered the
most evil sins of all more than things.
Notice killing, murder is not one of
them. Why? because killing is actually
murder is actually a byproduct [snorts]
of things like wrath and pride and greed
and envy.
So it wasn't mentioned but those when I
looked at those words [laughter]
far from actually talking about those
words or condemning them or teaching
children against them our entire society
is built on promoting and praising every
single one of those things. Pride isn't
that cornerstone of our civilization
especially when you have none. When you
do and engage in acts that have zero
pride in them, it's kind of interesting.
Um, lust. Oh my god, this is that's all
what what did I just get done talking
about these series? All they want to
show you is sex. Sex and more sex. The
kind of sex that never even happened.
Okay. Because they want to put it in
your mind that that's how it is. Um,
what else? Wrath, envy. These are all
things that are constantly glorified in
movies, right? Sloth.
Well, that's uh that that that's
basically I think one of the um least
appreciated
errors. That's what sins are. They're
errors. They're missing the mark that
really dominates especially western
culture. Uh greed. Greed. That's like a
hallmark of being a successful western
person, right? So um far from talking
about honor and virtue and things that
really really matter and make us better
people and make us have a more
qualitatively
superior life. We're constantly being
degraded by having around us what um
Christianity for centuries considered
were the absolute worst sins that we as
a people must constantly fight against.
They are what basically governs our
entire society. Think about that.
[music]
>> Bring [music] back the fire in the
rightous name. [music]